[Music]
yay
we are live now with
oola yes yeah
correct
hello
i'm so excited the ula costume has been
a very important alchemical role in the
no limits society and i'm really
grateful that
she accepted the invitation to come on
to the show and
to talk to us oh it's certainly my
pleasure
seriously i'm having such a good time
it's only been like
less than a month and really amazing
quite a few important waves and
realizations and
just so much fun so much better
yes yeah bentino and the team have done
a great job putting that container
together and then the
very realized people
in there get to play with one another
and create really strong ascensionary
dynamics and i've been
super humbled and grateful
and becoming more pure
through the process it's been nice do
you know what for me it came by such
surprise
because i've joined for the whole family
actually being more thinking about the
tennis teachings and
having access to what he does with the
mentorship group right
and then and the family chat group came
as a bonus
which my first thought was like oh no
not another group
right when i have to be talking and
stuff because um
i'm face to face type of person more
than on the phone
right so i'm like ah there you go
another group
but oh i left all the other groups since
and this is my you know favorite
yes yeah it's such a bonus for me
it's like i didn't expect that i'm going
to receive
so much great insight and amazing people
and uh yeah it's just this ongoing
conversation
and and playfulness like you say yeah
yeah that's the key is the whole idea of
not another group and then recognizing
that this is
actually the the
soul fam like the one where
it's like i don't really need other
group chats anymore like this is the one
where
it is so
playful and serious
[Music]
really like this is the juices squeeze
out of everything
like three weeks for me i think we're in
the fourth week now i am on a fourth
week i
tell us three weeks is like squeezing
the juice out
every single drop yeah and there like
you said like that
it's like not another group it's not
like another group it's just it just
isn't
it's different it's a v it's a
v group yeah there has yet there's yet
to be
a alchemical container that is
as anchored in the
realization of our true nature and then
as having
as strong of mirrors reflecting
that god's love light at one another to
purify the last bits of conditioning and
ego and psychology and self-dealing and
contraction
and and deception
and distortion and twists and all these
things and so
that's really the core thing is that
it's just like
pure pointing just
exactly all of that all of that i was
just watching just before you connected
i was watching continuous
uh become serious about being playful
right
i finished that one last night it was so
good okay
oh my oh my um france i had to wait till
i kind of got on the computer but
uh yeah he was talking about being
playful and about not being taking
serious
uh you know your play basically and
i i this group helped me so much to drop
seriousness
uh of what i think what i have to say
and about what i believe how does
beliefs become
just temporarily play for the for the
purpose of playing
uh momentary beliefs and they are able
to be dropped you know
next minute without any problem it's
just like oh okay that was fun for five
minutes now we moved on to another thing
um yeah and it because has been
challenged and
not just for me but i think for everyone
uh
so we he just you had to kind of
come to this place of like oh whatever
right i drop everything all at once
[Music]
it's kind of like
this one came up on our show recently
it's the giggle fest plus the
earnestness
merged into one so you have
the real playfulness plus the
seriousness merged into one
which is sort of another way of saying
this which is this kind of buddha
plus atlas
merged into one
i love it yeah totally you see that's
the thing i had a problem for some time
because i loved being in this place of
nothingness and just silence and things
and then there was this body that was
just like full of
expression that i wanted to do now i'm
like how do i put this two together
right how do they go together and it
took me some time quite a few weeks
probably some weeks really to kind of
feel like oh
that actually won the same emerge at
some point right
and and all of that comes out of this
nothingness all of this comes out of the
silence right
out of the groundless grand i like
calling it
um yeah
this is actually a really good place to
it's a really good place to play
together
because a lot of the
enlightenment dynamics
upon realization
in a sense
there's this we could say like a crevice
of a sort where a lot of
people will fall into something
like a nothingness
and then
what intelligent infinity is trying to
get you to do
is not to reside in nothingness
it's trying to get you after you
recognize your true nature
it's trying to get you to express
yourself
express yourself you know you go
firework
oh i was just thinking fireworks it's
like a fireworks comes with nothing and
it becomes all of this show
right that's exactly fireworks yeah
beautiful
fireworks coming out of me it's amazing
yeah
i think it was osha actually said this
uh thing that i want you to be a whole
man
and what whole man means is is
i said that how have people in
spirituality they go into nothingness
and they reject
the this reality right in the form from
my
reality and have the people go into
after this reality and reject the
nothingness the spiritual
uh you know silence and things and they
both
have they put they both not whole right
so i wanted to be a whole
being which contains both right
uh and that's perfect i think that's a
beautiful way of putting it
but that's the wholeness is having both
yes
yes that's a good one from
osho and then francis lucille
who also was the teacher of rupert spyra
eternal fireworks is another way of
putting it so yeah the wholeness
is totally being able to recognize
and then poof and the
proof express yourself part it is done
from a place of knowing your nature
because then
you don't get intoxicated by maya
when you express yourself by the
illusion by the dream
and rather i don't think that ullah
is a different separate
entity but i know that
underneath the costumes we are the same
one
infinite expressing itself as the
costumes and therefore
i recognize that i would never
commit malevolence against any of my own
costumes and actually what i
am when i'm divinely aligned when the
costumes divinely aligned with its true
nature
it can't help but just be in service to
the other costumes
yeah yeah totally totally is because
when you have this realization when you
have this knowing this within
it's like you just want everyone to feel
this to know this right
it's like if you see someone and they
take
themselves for not who they are and you
know they
potentiality and you know and know what
they
they're capable of and how they can live
their life you just can't help but i
wanted to
be of service to that and and guide
uh towards that direction it is kind of
guiding towards direction of
having um better happy life but it's
actually really direction
towards yourself right from which then
that better life unfolds
is this is kind of um
living a life from within from within
out rather than from the outing
which we haven't conditioned to do for
so many years
and how we all start really
yeah that was good that's this one
living from within out
that's great the fireworks comes because
from from that one
place outwards right it all comes from
one point
from that one point and it goes outwards
yes but we kind of try to
hold on to some of the things outside
and then
make ourselves something from it right
collect all of these things in our life
and ways
and then from all those collections and
ways of beings we want to come to some
kind of
way but it's the other way around um
that works much better i know amazing
you gotta go inward first
to go outward right it's the sure cause
of delight
[Laughter]
i've been playing around with these
little jingles
these cute jingles are so fun to
play with them there they've been told
for
you know 2 500 years of this parable of
the prodigal son
it's like you know you're gonna venture
outward not knowing your nature and
you're gonna hit
this wall of suffering
oh yeah okay then it'll force you to
turn
inward which then you recognize that the
nature
of your awareness itself
is that i am and then
the nature of that i am is bliss
and peace and then you live from
within outward
knowing that all is that i am
and that therefore i'm not going to
commit malevolence i am
only going to serve other costumes and
that that's
the name of the game yeah and i like
that how the giggles come from out as
well right
like because when you realize this
paradox and you realize how it
works you just can't help i have this
little giggle i find myself you know
doing exactly that
a lot and all sorts of different tunes
and some come in different situations
like oh
that's one kind of it's just it just
becomes really more playful
um an adventist thing it just becomes
you can't take things too seriously
because you know
you've created all of this right you
know you've created a lot of this
suffering for yourself to wake yourself
up and
and you know you've creating just
another situation and you just kind of
go around like
okay thanks you know oh oh hi great
um it's all it all becomes like
like a little fun game to play life
and you just just constantly in a place
of wonder it's like oh i wonder what
what's what's going to come you know out
of this or what's going to unfold next
and uh that kind of instead of curiosity
this uh they said they call it you know
in child
for innocence and curiosity
yes yes it is that um
yeah the eyes wide open it's like oh
this and that
but again not taking too seriously not
getting lost in it
if we can yeah there's these two good
ones from
osho i take your trouble seriously but
deep inside i am giggling
yeah exactly and then there's
there's this one too which is
uh when i look at you
i am searching for a chip
and and that we do upon realization
like you said it makes
the
when i remember when i was a kid we
would
take remember the the excitement level
that we would have for the very
simple things like when you have your
little marker box and that you're
drawing that you're drawing
and you know on the show that i did on
intelligent infinity a couple of days
ago
when i picked up the marker box to draw
i was like
yay marker box and so
that's what we're talking about it's
that level of
you know you're sitting out here and
you're watching
a hummingbird just fly over to the
flower and enjoy the nectar
and you just are in awe at
that and every single
perfection
and just that rhythm
is all that is meant by enlightenment
that is the nature
is right here just bliss peace
eternity ineffability
yeah totally i totally i tell her to get
in i love that
thing of um you know it doesn't matter
what happens around
and how much noise it's around and how
much playfulness or even
seriousness or something then that's
that's only like
happening but further beyond that
it's always this place of peace
and and effortlessness and
and and just complete stillness right
so it doesn't matter how much movement
and how much noise is happening
you can still in all of this access that
point of stillness
and complete peace and that's just
that's just mind-blowing having those
two together
at the same time is like oh it's
seriously
it's just such beauty love it
[Music]
to know yeah go ahead i've experienced
that exactly being at festival
and being in the right in the middle of
ecstatic dancing with about 200 people
in a tent you're like music really going
and we're all dancing and suddenly i
just felt like
oh there's a buddha inside of me right
and i saw this little buddha with across
the legs and sitting here and suddenly
i was still moving i was still dancing
music was still going but it was just a
complete stillness of the same place on
this
incredible intense um intensity that was
going around me right
and doing it upon ecstatic dance
is great and then being able to
do it upon a
moment of
stress or anxiety or depression or
fear or jealousy or anger any of these
negative valence states is
even more jedi full and masterful
and that's when we really become
wizards when we get to that stage when
you just get to watch the cloud of anger
arise and then pass and just stay as
that
complete
imperturbable peaceful eternal
witnessing sky in which the cloud
happens
and that's when you really like you say
this child opens up because you no
longer
become a slave to the clouds that arise
and
pass but you maintain the
simultaneity of being a giggle
while being uh being serious about your
calling
right that's sort of that's what that's
what these two are like there's the
buddha the cosmic joke
and then there's the there's the atlas
the serious calling
and you merge them together and you get
a
a really well realized
expression of infinity because it's not
bathed in nothingness and it's not
expressing itself from a place of lack
and so it's beautiful and harmonic
yeah yeah i love it yeah
i tell you when it started with me
really properly and
deeply and it really never left me since
tell us
three years ago when i fell apart into
pieces like seriously
like hit the rope button beyond uh
imagination
and i saw myself crashing into hundreds
of pistols right
and i look at these pieces and they're
just like i don't know how i'm ever
ever going to be able to put this
together again right like put myself
back together it was just like
impossible and then i look at those
pieces and i had this moment of
of um realization that
if i am looking at those pieces and i i
have broken into 100 pieces then
who is this me who is into pieces and
who's this me that is looking in the
species right
and that realization of that me
that is looking at the pieces is
it was so strong for me and it it was
free
very very difficult three year process
of you know putting
these pieces together in different ways
however
it has been very very very very
difficult
but that me that presence has never left
right so whatever was happening in this
whole process
the presence the me that i am
presence was always always uh
there with me with me with other me
right
uh so yeah and that was when it sat
very very deeply and strongly with me
and uh
it has been other things what was
the catalyst the drill sergeant
of suffering for your awakening three
years ago
what broke you into a hundred pieces of
love
accumulation of events of the
accumulation of you know fears but
uh but what was the the tipping point
was the
last relationship i had which i was so
strongly in love
incredible and that it broke my heart
very severely i would say if there's
something like that like broken heart
because i know it isn't
but at that time i felt like i was
completely heartbroken on the top of it
i became
very seriously sick physically uh
ill right i came back from bali with
some strange disease which was like
knocking me completely i was not going
to survive this uh i'm still here
but yeah um so heartbrokenness with this
uh
very challenging um physical
illness put together
that was yeah that was it that was it
for me
those are serious uh long-term
relationship
ending plus a strange disease
that feels like is ending your existence
it finished me that was it it finished
all out
that time she was got she was gone she
was finished
[Laughter]
yeah there you go you know i've gained
something
much more important and beautiful and
and permanent if you can call it like
that right
something that is indestructible so in
my distraction i realized that
i can't be destroyed like it's not
possible you know my failures i realized
that
that is impossible to fail all right
uh that's that in this moment of
complete
uh crash and
not being able to find grand we find
completely new grant the grantless grant
the the bag brand um
[Music]
it reminds me a lot of
when you say the realization
awakens us to our indestructibility
reminds me a lot of the sufi metaphysic
[Music]
which means the unity of all finding
and it's referring to
how each of these expressions of
intelligent infinity
have that gps callback as continuous
says
and then as we go and do this gps
callback process
that the ula costume will have her own
unique taste
and style of finding and union yoga
and with god with absolute
with intelligent infinity to re-commune
with that to recognize oneself as that
and the atlas costume has
its own union and so
what is the unity of all of that
finding happening like love dub lub dub
lub dub like the heartbeat itself like
the unity of all of that finding
and that every single one of us has our
own unique taste and style
of finding and so we become
a realization itself is
completely indestructible nobody can
take
that realization away it's so
sacred divine beautiful
yeah yeah to tell you about that it is
amazing is that i love this watching
stories of different people how they
realized and how every story is
different yet they realize the same
right only from different angle like
completely like
just just amazing that's why when i was
following before all of that when i was
following all different teachers i kind
of felt like oh maybe this is how i'm
going to
you know how this is going to happen for
me or maybe like this and we can get
stack of how this is supposed to be look
like right
and never prepared actually to how it's
going to hold for
uh for that body vessel
expression in costume as you call it uh
i love this all different flavors
and different ways and i think that's
the being of service um
for me is you know because three times i
was asked so can you tell
people how to get there like there where
can you tell people can you tell people
what to do
i can't i can only guide them back to
their own ways right to find to to
to follow that that inner calling the
inner part that you know
uh excitement and go bit by bit with
that and find confidence in following
absolutely following what's coming from
here and not from anywhere else
right even even the teachings itself
are themselves they find their own
unique way
yeah to from her
to from unique way of expressing that
freedom
finding that freedom
yeah in a certain way the
the ula costume flower
has its unique aroma of expression
and then the atlas costume flower has
its
own unique aroma
and
there's a simultaneity with the
flower costume aroma
finding its own unique way of expressing
while also asking other costumes hey
you know i'm suffering because i'm
addicted to
maya what do i do
and then the answer is go within
and when you go within you become
more and more they're these little gym
repetitions to become more and more
aware of awareness
itself and in doing so
recognize the
bliss and peace and also recognize
that it itself is shared impersonal
eternal just like our
source is and so
these realizations
they come
to those as the flowers expressing
that are feeling like there's
maya that it is being
intoxicated and
whereas if you're the flower that's
expressing itself
from very conscious very enlightened
parents
or an indigenous tradition where the
child's birth
right into knowing themselves as
infinity expressing
itself in just complete awareness of
nothingness and everythingness
what ego forms what onion layers are
there to shed
and so that's part of sort of the future
that we're looking at is a
a planetary pedagogy that
recognizes our true nature
from birth and therefore never
forms the egoic hitchhiker although it
serves us
as a drill sergeant of awakening
that was a very 3d
third density matrixy
aspect to our creation and we are
birthing children into the 4d
fourth density love green heart chakra
cosmic unity consciousness era
yeah i mean even if you have parents
that are quite
you know already focusing on spiritual
matters and um you know more aware and
things it will it still was very hard i
think
anywhere not everywhere but in many
places
you still went meet friends you still
went
the you know your schools your work and
stuff so
it was no choice to not get receive this
conditioning from
everywhere like all different directions
like home is just one
one little bit right and your parents
but everywhere else it's exactly the
same you're just
literally born into the conditioning and
then you are
you know as a as a young person
ready to live um you know home parents
home be going to the world
fully conditioned right like fully
conditioned um
and not knowing uh who we are a lot of
the time
at this for me it's fully because you
know i'm from poland
catholic church community so like
seriously like
i remember having the feeling i must be
dumped here by mistake right there's
something not right here
and yeah the conditioning you know
brought me into my knees it really did
this had to break down this is what
needed to break down into 100 pieces
right
it was that um which was quite a
grace
and but not right now what's happening i
mean more people awakening
and looking into
who they truly are where they truly come
from
and being more and more connected with
the inner selves
and in the source there's a different
style of bringing children right it's
more opportunities to bring them
differently
they're all different new projects new
schoolings new ways of being you know
going in the jungle going
completely off going completely off and
living your life in different styles
it's just amazing it's so nice to see
i've got two children aged nine and ten
so as i'm going through my process i had
to i have to undo
or help them and do uh things that have
already been done to them right
uh guide them and then guide them
further lucky i still have go about
eight years before they leave so you
know
i'm hoping to be able to participate to
start them off
at least on this
beautiful ways of knowing who you are
then going
and creating right from that place um
yes this is my favorite i this is my
favorite one
one of my favorite parts to the creation
is post
realization to be a conscious parent
that's so cool it's so cool
i know amazing it's hard as well
right because it's um as i go from my
own process and i'm a single mother
right now
i'm going through my own or i have been
going for my difficulties
and then have to take care of them but i
can see myself acting
so much different with them right it's
like it's like wow
and uh part of that is all the things
that we heal you know this is this is
the most mind-blowing thing because
we're talking quantum physics right
so whatever you're able to process and
clear within your own being
it's being almost taken out
automatically for the
from children right because the genetics
because on energy level that has been
sitting here and
on major level it was passed on to child
so if that energy
is that if that that dense energy has
been cleared
it's been cleared from all the places
right
it's been cleared the top it's been
cleared you know totality has
been done clearly totally but i see as i
change with my ways of bidding i have
been changing i see
how how how my my children automatically
pick up right
and they change automatically that's the
most mind-blowing for me
like i don't even have to do anything
with them and
for them all i have to do is here
perfect
and that that that just comes out it
shows itself
you know in that way and then
yeah oh my gosh when the parent is
bliss peace presence energy it is
exactly what is
the mimetic component for the kid
kids are constantly doing mimesis
a very important term from rene girard
which is
that you take and you copy
and paste to your own actions we copy
and paste
and if the if the parent is
freaking out endlessly about existence
child will if the parent has that bliss
peace presence energy because they've
done the work themselves
now what's happened as you say in things
like
we're finding in quantum biology
that we have epigenetics we have
the dna methylation the histone tails we
have these biomarkers
that also end up coming onto our code of
life
itself that then makes it so that
when our kids also have kids
that downstream we're actually
ending trauma we're ending ego we're
ending density we're ending conditioning
psychology onion layers that
are purely the product
of a third density creationary matrix
which was
beautiful
but we are ascending beyond yeah
totally i i even so how it happens when
you've got it you go
you've got a hurt in a child and that it
creates the
it going increases the false beliefs
right because each the child gets hurt
and it starts creating a belief about
the world
by the people about themselves so that
kind of creates a little
monster i call it like a little monster
little unloved unlovable
and worthy whatever right and secure
being which is the entity itself but
it's just living in the human body right
that like hitchhiker like was talking
about it
yes so and then if that kind of
adult being has children right then this
little this little entity the monster is
going to
come out and jump up that child on so
many levels some occasions that's going
to click create its own
baby monster in this child right i call
it a monster because it's uh it really
looks like this sometimes right
so this entity within the border of
human being
is then creating the baby entity in a
small human being right that's how it's
been passed from generation to
generation it's all kind of on energy
level happens
so the moment when um a mother father
starts doing this work and clears the
whole entity
and cleaves itself from this entity and
becomes pure being
that entity in child it becomes starts
dissolving
right because it is it's created of the
same substance
it's created from from that one so it
it starts dissolving on an energy level
in in the
body of the child as well it's beautiful
and children are just mirrors just just
like you can't avoid to see yourself in
your child it's just like
it's in your face
[Music]
this is why precision consciousness is
so
critical it's
so much about going in
to recognize true nature to awaken
to the already always free
bliss peace ineffable
perfection which then carries itself as
presence energy which then butterfly
effects
outward as precision consciousness
to awaken other costumes he
so powerful right so beautifully
powerful
that's the power isn't it that's this
that's that's the true power when you
become it
right because you are it by when you
really fully
conscious uh and aware of this of of
of yourself as this power you
you don't really have to be that much uh
you know there's not that much action
it's just that pres the presence of that
power itself
it's touching like you walk into the
place and
and and all the people around are
transformed in some ways right
but just by that energy that you're
carrying they're just being transformed
without even knowing right they're being
touched on some levels and some of them
might feel
you know more lighter and and beautiful
and some of them might feel even more
triggered right so they're
but whatever whatever needs to be doing
that energy it just
is happening i had those experiences
three times as well
when i fell so fully in in the power
that i walked into the place with
people around and i knew i i knew i i
just knew that they were all touched
right and i and i i didn't even have to
speak to anyone i didn't have to
do anything just just carrying that
presence with you is just the most
potent
thing for transformation
[Music]
yeah and we are that
we can tell the energetic signature
when we are that it
sounds and vibrates and feels
like a very warm
warm warm
and then you can tell that when it's
not that when you haven't
glimpsed tasted recognized your nature
the energy in a sense it comes off like
this and i
i need this and i need that and can i
take this extract this from maya
and the vibration is
more like
i love those noises and those
demonstrations
yeah so which one do we want a butterfly
effect outward
right that's the question that's where
the will
the choice the discernment
comes which one which one
which one which one which one
which one do you want god's love light
do you want that
[Music]
the harmonic or do you want what is out
of
tune and creating war and poverty and
destruction
and suffering and malevolence on the
planet
which one yeah
it's like playing instrument days in
tune and it creates the beautiful
the most beautiful stunning clear sand
right
and having those instruments are
completely messed up and all over the
place and then trying to make a scent
of it it's a lot of that kind of stunt
going on in the world right now
distorted
symphony analogy for the nature of
reality
is very beautiful because
it
enables intelligent infinity to both
be one infinite creator symphony
yet also have the individuated firework
aspect
to it which is that the uula costume
gets to be this incredible violinist
meanwhile this atlas costume gets to
play the saxophone
and in doing
and recognizing our nature as that
it makes it so that we can both
celebrate the ineffable unity
being expressed as this
very illusory yet gorgeous diversity
yeah totally i like that universe is
where the pediatrician immediately is a
universe right
this is like one big you know song
yeah it's so beautiful like it's even
cold like this right
it's just like that's what it is and
then we have all these different
tongs and instruments and you know and
different rhythms
and uh it's just just and it just
creates the one big symphony because
that is so beautiful
i love this moment see because we used
to live life
being the doer right of things thing to
do where and you know this is
all i'm saying there's she she thinks
this and she's doing this and she's
doing that i
but actually when you are not when allah
gets out of the way
and i am being i am this body as a body
vessel
it's being played like an instrument by
the you know
divine power and when when it this
instrument is being danced all right by
this
power is just nothing composed of this
feeling
just just nothing compares to that
feeling really
of um being played rather than playing
playing dance rather than dancing it's
completely different experience
um yes is this effortlessness is this
joy is this
yeah because on the car we are just
so beautifully it's so beautifully
joyfully playful and ecstatic right
it really is the whole creation it's
just like a that the
experience is like one big ecstatic
creation there's so much ecstasy filling
in in all of this like even
how the flowers opens up it just looks
so much
ecstasy in it like or when the when the
wave
hits the rocks right uh
it's just it honestly it's just one big
ecstasy sometimes
for me i'm like oh
oh my god oh more of this
and that paradigm moves it all the power
that moves it oh
and we are that um
ooh that was a good one let's add
let's add that one in there boom
we are the one power that moves
it all uh yeah it is
it's so fun for when you realize here
it's so obvious that it's just one
breath
it's not many breaths it's just one
breath breathing us all right
it's just one heart beating through each
of us right it's just
one mind that works for all of us
right it's one body it's just one body
moves us all that is being moved and and
we are all part of that one body
so there's no more you know that's
that's the one
that's that's the one one heart one love
one mind
one body one love it's just all
that's the one one beautiful one that's
realization of that is
it's like you know it's like having so
many million trillions billions of cells
in the body
and they all and they're all separate
yeah in a kind of in a way because they
are separate cells however
they are they are one body they are
working
in that unity for for the
good of the body right so i see
when we when we fall back to
where we came from we are this healthy
cells that are working
towards the good of the totality of the
body right that's where we
become automatically in the service
because
that's what we do that's what we're here
for we are to work towards the good
of this body right that is being created
so we become this you know carriers of
the
information and of the law of love
information
hell vitality happiness joy and
all of the all of what wellness and
well-being of this
universe body means
that's what those two analogies
merge together are so beautiful
the symphony with the body analogy
where playing in tune is the very
healthy cell
and playing out of tune is the
pathological
cell yep exactly
and there's one heart one mind
one love one body
one power and in the
recognizing that one
is the spark of intelligent infinity
that can be
analogized as a neuron
as a unique gift a unique firework a
unique expression
in the one heart one mind
one love one body
what more could
enlightenment be than sinking into that
perfection
that is fireworking and filling
oneself feeling the already present
bliss peace and butterfly affecting that
out
yeah totally and you see what
once you become one with the whole body
one with the one mind one with
one heart and one love you have got
access
to intelligence right to that
intelligence so
you have got access to so much um
so much information uh that can be then
utilized and used so it's creating more
good right
towards the service like they call it
you need to be in service
because all that information is
available to you like if you have got if
you are
stuck with a little human mind you've
got only this much information as this
box can contain right
that's as much as you can but when this
goes away
it's just this opens up right and
that's all they have access to
information
and it can whatever needs to come to you
always comes to in the right time you
don't even have to
think about it you don't have to go and
read books you don't have to
you've got access through your body
through this vessel you've got access to
all of that right you can access the
creation of the universe
through reconnecting with the you know
what your what your body's build off i
had this beautiful journey
to back to stars exploding like oh
that's what it means i'm a stardust
i know now because i have traveled back
there right because i connect
reconnected with my body wisdom
with the information stored in the body
and there we
are oh the stars exploded and that's
you know it just was shown to me and so
many things are shown to me like this
which
i wouldn't okay i could read some books
about it right and stuff
but it's completely different than
seeing it and knowing in this way than
just
reading it as a story from some book
all of this information is stored we
have it
it's like we are the that we are the
library of the universe right
we really are we are the full library of
the whole universe
um once you become one with it you've
got access to this library
uh there's some moments when i had
this openings and i was shown how the
universe is created and
how the word is created like a the word
fault
intention and comprehension and then
action and how it's created i'm like oh
my god
this is like material for free books
right i've sit down but of course this
kind of went away and
um i can deliver this information
in in easy ways anymore only bits of it
are left with me
but you just get access to this and you
know just like that
that's the beauty of the power of the
intelligence i like to call it an engine
as well the engine lorenzo all right as
well
yeah the library is
talked about also in the spiritual
has the akashic records
and so you'll never come to the end of
all of the different ways that you can
explore
of all the different ways that you can
express
all the different ways that god's love
light leela can play
with itself never ever
ever ever possible to come to an end
you're the source
of infinite possibilities and just
relax into
the embodied recognizing
that i am that
[Music]
ah yes
and it's so natural to have the feeling
of this
ineffable bliss
piece
for the other
costumes in the i am
to not
feel that
is a trauma is a wound
is a kink twist distortion
that is very naturally being expressed
and yet
is seeking the healing of said confusion
back into alignment with that
love light bliss peace so naturally
there's the feeling of
being in service to that yeah
totally because you see i was thinking
about it
because i was asked by someone to write
a written article
and i wanted to write about uh how the
caterpillar became a butterfly right
because
when i look at when i look at this
previous uh form of self
it was it almost like it's this little
caterpillar walking so close to the
ground you know only seeing so much
because
she's so tiny she couldn't see past the
grass right
because the view is uh it's kind of
completely
right so then you you just literally
underscore people but you're living
quite happily or whatever you just
accept your caterpillar and you just
live like that a lot of people live like
a caterpillar and they are
okay with it right however there's some
caterpillars when they
they just walk and there's something
like just something doesn't feel hundred
percent right like they have a feeling
that there is
more that there is something else that
life is a bit
more than this since very
since the beginning i was born i didn't
even know about soul
and stuff i already knew that there's a
part of me that has
this body and part of me that never dies
right i knew this before i was told
about seoul
i also knew i had this thing coming like
i'm here for something bigger i'm here
for something bigger i'm here for
something bigger
and i never never knew what that
something bigger was i thought i was
going to be a
pop star or something like that right i
thought something bigger meant that i'm
going to be famous
but of course now i know that's not that
wasn't exactly that
but anyway so there are those
caterpillars that just feel
that there's so much but there's
something else there right and this
this set of people will start kind of
looking around
and these are the people that we are
here
like once you like once you open your
wings and you are about to fly and you
fly right and
you jump from flower to flower when you
see the caterpillars they are
thinking oh my god this could they look
at this
butterfly and they have this feeling
that there must be something there
these are the people these are the other
costumes that we just like wanted like
yes let me tell you all about it right
let me let me help you let me guide you
let me tell you let me
let me you know hold your hand while
you're walking there
and there's this beautiful period of
going in the cocoon and becoming pile of
goo
which i know very well when you go over
a period of time when you complete
goo in a darkness and you are you know
uh
going through all this wonderful uh
you know this like you just being
disintegrated completely
you like feel like dying um because you
are in a way the caterpillar is
dying right and the butterflies are
going to come out of it
so they said these are the costumes
that i am very excited about right
for me this is the excitement uh this is
the excitement like yes
you're right thinking this right you are
rightly thinking you know
and that there's something else and
something more and um
and i heard this i saw this picture
yesterday it said
how to become a butterfly you have to
want it so much that you prepared to
give up being caterpillar
right i love this i really love that you
have to
want it you want you have to want it so
much
so much now you're prepared to give up
being caterpillar
and i think that's the beautiful way um
to yeah my own way which i discovered
yesterday of
you know speaking about it really
and having this view
little view from the ground and having
this view as a
butterfly but then you've got then you
go bird view right which is even
further into that and you can go on and
on
and like you said there's never end to
how far this can take you because
there's so many different facets of
true i've i've also realized you know
there's one
that says that which is true
uh that this is a dream it doesn't even
have reality right because i have also
experienced this
being like completely unreal
like uh uh
i got harry potter i forgot what's now
um like stimulation and i like it like a
complete and
he hasn't got i didn't have any i didn't
have any real substance to me at all
i was completely unreal and every
experience was not real i
i knew that i'm not driving a car just
created the experience of driving a car
going from one place to another but it
never happened i just created the
experience
uh i've just created the experience of
doing it but i've never actually done
that ever
right um so and then you go
then you have uh exterminate so many
facets of truth
different angles to look at it and every
one of them
you know all of them are equally true
but they're just different angles to
look at it right
[Music]
yeah there's so much good stuff there
there's the
simultaneity of there never
being a caterpillar turning into a
butterfly and yet
also the only constant being that the
caterpillar endlessly turns into
butterflies
and that
can we go beyond both and just
be ineffable perfection
and
can we also recognize that
given that we are
in the middle of this dreamed
metamorphosis
can we inspire
and butterfly effect out
the earnestness and the desire
to give up the caterpillar for the
butterfly
yeah but then after that even give out
the butterfly right
and give up the butterfly
[Music]
yep
that was that tiny was saying on this
video just a while ago
when he said give up only all your
all your ideas all your beliefs like you
know can you give them all of that
point of views right pandava call it
it's all
you know if you take if you if you
consider that all of this point of view
then if you give all of them up what's
left even you even this body even the
ola
in form of caterpillar or formal
butterfly or whatever other form
it's still point of view right it says
this tree is
point of view like this world is a point
of view and i just love the conversation
with my friend he said yeah but even the
law of physics you know we can argue
that they only
are um there are their
beliefs right that agreed upon uh upon
beliefs as well
uh on some deeper level actually when he
said that i had this realization oh my
god yes
i still believe right and when i go i
went as far as the
law of physics and stuff becoming
beliefs that that
completely wiped off the whole world
again for me um
when even that is a point of view you
can go as far
as completely erasing all points of view
and coming coming to the place of
zero zero point
when you give up the
egoic conditioned psychology
separation infinity form
layers of identity
beliefs perceptions sensations emotions
thoughts
which is very much like has been taught
by the nettie nettie
not that's not that yeah
to become aware of awareness and then to
become aware of oneself as
the absolute and then to include
peacefully blissfully
all big bangs all creation being the
source of infinite possibility
and then to just rest in
that very beyondness
the very
eternal stage on which the leela
takes place
as god's love light
the very white network theory
the very warm warm
dreamed metamorphosis warm
warm warm
the same speed at which the hummingbird
flaps its wings that we
make big bangs
and use the vehicle
that we've designed
to experience
those big bangs
and to recognize that those are all
beautiful
dreams and there is this stillness
behind and beyond it all
just be
be beyond
be a kid in awe
dancing playful butterfly affecting out
that vibration
yeah it is beautiful it is really
beautiful and
it is um i find the challenge in that as
well
in i think it was november last year
when i have really hit the absolute
um the place beyond
the wall doesn't exist right and um
and this was this this fell home like
like the home and uh
i have later some part of
this um rejected
rejected this expression right and i
wanted to reject the world he wanted to
reject the expression the form
evolved and
it took me quite some time
[Music]
to bring myself back into expression
and the realization that and that
actually also started at the very
beginning
when i joined the group only last month
properly
i already had some kind of experiences
of um
soul retrieval and things like that but
um
i think he had to do something with
video with continue i'm not sure exactly
how it happened i can't remember now
but it brought me to realization
deeper deeper realization that um
this expression and the place beyond the
world they also manage
somewhere right and it's like and at
some point i
had to accept that if
god and beyond god wants
is i don't know if he's the right way to
say but that's how i feel
how he feels for me it is that if you if
you didn't
want this expression you would never
created it right
it's like it would always stay the same
and never created that
and we would never be here somehow
somehow the idea came somehow the
um comprehension or anticipation or or
so somehow it came this this
this desire for something else right
or getting to know itself through
something else
um so it's all
equally valid kind that's what i had to
come and accept and from that place it's
building more and more
absolutely loving the expression right
loving the
the form shape expression and
and and making fun
with it uh and play and
just like just fireworks like that's
this is exactly
the fireworks came back right into this
by the expression and it was go wow
i'm back right here i'm back
about in completely different
from completely different place again
even you know from deeper space
and if i can call it like that i still i
still
quite find difficult to ward these
things
right i find difficult toward
all of that um but i
you know that's kind of why i
feel
we are the will for possibility we are
the will for creativity we are the will
for expression we are the will for
fireworks we are the will for
leela all dreamed
yet so beautiful
the atlas and oola costumes had a very
good dialectic super good
the eye with itself through these
costumes was super high level
it was really good
[Music]
i'm so grateful that was fire
okay
yeah it's just so nice that's why
you know i thank you i'm really grateful
for the invitation because
and right now with you and the group
is such joy to be able to connect on
this level
and to be able to resonate on this level
right because
this is where we meet is we've done any
more meat
on the street i have a bear or
the dance which is also called we read
like that as well
but we meet so much deeper than this
right
we we know each other differently
we know each other from that i i you're
i know you you me young you you you me
right this is just
it's just the one expressing in in this
different voices in
different shapes right now but it's
speaking
for both of us equally and
and uh knowing and seeing that and
feeling it from both
from both um views right
onto each other is pure joy for me
really is
[Music]
soon to also gather more
in person as well as this
hyper ascensionary pure collective to
both rise up
purify as well as anchor the
architectures
to move more costumes from the 3d to the
4d
to unlocking that heart chakra to get to
that
cosmic unity wakefulness
so this is what we are
up to and you can
join in if you guys would like will
put some information below to
no limits society for the family
as well as some of ula where's a good
place for people to
follow you online website instagram
youtube do you have any of the socials
yeah
i have instagram which i don't use that
much i'll probably use a bit more
soon once i get because i'm in this um
transition time here um physical ward
um i do use facebook as well these are
mainly
my things but will i estimate them
[Music]
is this becoming this integrated cells
right to solve them knowing
what they're here for that they are here
for the good
of all right that we all here for
creating
you know harmony creating harmony
and love and peace and uh and
sharing and cooperating and working
together seemingly separate
yet one underneath
yeah yeah the exciting time
that's great i like that seemingly
separate yet one underneath
[Music]
so we got a wrap
thank you everyone for tuning in we are
very grateful
for you we would love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below
write us a message down there
your thoughts on the conversation and
like the video if it brought you value
it helps the algorithm and
subscribe if you haven't and share the
video with people that you feel like
this would positively influence
and
that is all we adore you infinitely
wait there's just love isn't it wait
that's that's the future as well as well
we might
play like with some enemies or strangers
or boyfriends or partners or parents or
ex partners whatever but
and we might find this strange different
in different interactions and relating
but underneath
there's nothing but love for each other
just there's pure love
for each other right and for every
single expression
um to aid to to get to that place of
to find that place of this pure love
unconditional
and then and then you go into the world
and you just can't help but love people
we just can't help but love everyone
right
i can't help but just really really want
to um
bring more of this and share more of it
and spread it and make it a new virus
making the new
catchy and to see you right the new
catchy
virus uh that's that's that's just
uh that's what's happening in a way it's
we are full in full blown of it i think
with the the corona is distraction to
actually what's happening
properly it's just really stirring it up
and bringing it more it's the you know
the one of the
what i've learned as well is when the
dark comes in he only comes to bring
more light kind of right
so when something is taking us down is
to
for us to find our power to find our
light
from within so when i was you know
pushed and pressed and
you know into the floor that's where the
light
was found so we beautifully getting
there
we're beautifully getting there we're
ready there anyway there's another way
ah yeah we created the drill sergeant
for the awakening of suffering yeah it's
so beautiful
and nobody actually in the final
analysis suffers nobody else
in the final analysis it's so funny
i know because the diagonal line there
are like lovers right the
dancers the dark and the light in this
world they are the ongoing dancers right
they complement each other that enhance
each other
i kind of wore their needs we need some
more light so we're going to bring more
dark so to bring more lighter
again it's just it's just an undergoing
beautiful play
um they were able to witness
both are costumed as
the one light the one
monist light that is costumed as
half light and half dark dancing
yeah that's why the taijitsu a thousand
years ago jiaodun yi
now they knew across all these cultures
which was
you put the monist and the dualistic yin
yang together in one
symbol and you have the nature right
there boom
yay
beautiful thanks everybody for tuning in
we will
see you soon i will end the stream and
you and i will stay in here for a bit
okay
okay thank you very much take care thank
[Music]
you